foreign
[Music]
everybody what's going on it's Friday
night we're getting ready to go out
after the show so that's why we're a
little bit late starting because you
know I always have my makeup disasters
and various other things she's always
getting [__] in her eye
well it's not even it's not I'm not
doing it on purpose it's like [__] just
gets in my eye hair makeup women problem
it's yeah and then like just my eye just
starts watering and once it starts
watering it won't stop watering and so
like when I put makeup on it just like
runs everywhere yeah so I have to keep
like blotting it and blotting it and
blotting it and then I have to keep
going like that to keep it from [__]
[__] up my [__] yeah
sucks yeah
so uh we're gonna Usher you guys out to
your weekend
uh whether or not you're gonna stay at
home or if you're going to go out to
we're going out we're going to be we're
probably the show's only going to go on
for about an hour right hour and a half
maybe
yeah something like that because it
doesn't open until 10 so we don't have
to leave until like 9 30. so we'll just
we'll talk about anything you guys want
to talk about uh or we'll just sit here
and [__] ramble about [__] basic
[__] or random [__] that we talk about
uh there's been some paranormal stuff
that's been happening in the news
evidently uh there's a guy leaking at
the uh got a government leaker talking
about UFOs that they have [__]
crashed vehicles and pieces of them and
bodies
uh
I don't believe it I don't believe that
either I think it's a psyop
I think they're just trying to distract
from other problems
but um
other than that we're just going to see
who's who's in the chat Jim
zag and Camp guy and Tammy and Tyler the
guy
so yeah yeah Zach and I were talking as
I was getting ready for the show I was
listening to [__] Judas Priest
watching Rob Halford live and he was
getting me hyped so I went full leather
daddy tonight I'm going full leather
jacket he's all shiny and everything I
got my [__] boots
[Laughter]
yeah
that's a good
uh let's see at least Zach said at least
Jenny's nose didn't have its period like
I showed Tom earlier yeah zag's nose
would bleeding oh [__] yeah
Trey said uh woohoo I saw the sisters
Monday then I was wondering why Tom was
wearing that [__]
I didn't know about the sisters so how
uh so how was that yeah I've seen them
lots of times but I think the last time
we saw them was several as many years
ago we saw them together didn't we
at least once or did we we never saw
sisters together okay I've seen them a
bunch of times yeah like
with the friends with my ex-husband a
few times like yeah I think I've seen
them like three or four or five times
something like that I've kind of like
forgot I used to keep track of all the
shows that I went to
but
I stopped keeping track and now I don't
remember
it's like and I've seen so many that I'm
just kind of like wait did I even see
that band or [__] I don't remember
um Trey said the music was great but
Andrew can't sing very well anymore
um I'm glad I went it was cool to be
back in Detroit for a few days
yeah I mean how old is Andrew Eldridge
now yeah
oh I don't know old
yeah old Tyler's asked me isn't leather
[__] hot in uh Florida this isn't
leather yeah it's just a shiny flexible
material yeah
it was fake leather leather look
it actually
what would you call that Jen it's
actually a checkerboard pattern yeah
different kinds of gloss black I mean
people do it is it's hard being a goth
in Florida that's for sure like even if
you don't wear leather which I mean I
wouldn't advise it but
wearing leather but some people do yeah
but um yeah it's it's hot but when the
pants are cotton
only the Leathers the boots yeah
uh 62 Andrew Eldridge is 62. now Trey
said [__] being a goth in Georgia sucks
yeah I mean anywhere where it's hot you
just can't
you can't like get all I mean you can
but you'll die of like [__] heat
stroke you know yeah and he's not a good
62 actually I haven't seen him in a long
time I mean I'm pushing 60. I'll dust
that [__] off you know it's just
he's not a very good 62. he but he
wasn't a good 42.
he's just you know
I think he's got mental issues too like
I said I don't know I haven't seen him
for a long time so
Camp guy said just got back from Florida
vacation I've never seen such
development between Destin and Panama
City Panhandle in 20 years condos
townhouses yeah built out super high
density housing and kitchen shops yeah
everything's corporate now the whole
South is Corporate everything is set in
Mississippi
is a collapsing [__] State
everybody's leaving
there's nothing there
no there's nothing there except on the
uh the coast all the casinos so you got
Biloxi past Christiane I live down there
I loved [__] past Christiana Biloxi
area but that's it that's all you got
and that's just if you're gonna live on
the coast you might as well just keep on
going and just end up being on the floor
to panhandle
and then just keep on going and then
you're new Orlando
uh Zach's talking about the forest fires
in Canada yeah it's I had been hearing
about that and they actually
um because a woman that works with me
was going on vacation I don't remember
where she was going but they were
canceling all the flights because of all
the smoke and everything like that which
is crazy because that's all the way in
[__] Canada
they're set on purpose too there's a a
satellite photo that showed that they
broke out at about four different places
simultaneously and there was
hundreds of miles apart or dozens of
miles but I couldn't really tell the
scale in the satellite photography so
that was done by a team that set those
on fire at the same time
you're trying to drive people out I
think I think they're trying to drive
people out of wooded areas make
everybody move to cities so they could
do those smart cities that's what I
think it is
or it could just be fired
no fires can't happen simultaneously
with such space in between them they
were set by a team
just was all you need is cell phones
and a and a dedicated group of guys that
are doing [__]
might have been something like antifa or
something something like that something
somebody higher
might have been insurance companies
there's no way of knowing
it was not natural though
trying to be action Trey says uh the
fact that I'm only the only goth in this
[__] town yeah I mean you know
growing up in Daytona it was a little
bit like that there was more than one
but not that many it was like a handful
it was like that for me on several
occasions having to go back home to
Mississippi for a few months before I
could find my way out of there like in
the central part
a Mississippi looking I was driving two
hours to go to New Orleans to the French
Quarter to uh might have been two and a
half hours uh just to go to the club
every weekend sometimes I couldn't make
it back and say [__] it I'm sleeping in
the car
I'll leave in the morning you know it's
a long [__] howl that's that's how I
met my first wife met her at the club
there and then ended up living with her
I passed Christian there's a way out of
it being in a small town just got to get
out
you got to get out of the area and go to
the clubs
I was driving two and a half hours to go
to him
yeah I was too because I used to live in
Daytona and I would drive to Tampa to go
to the castle on the weekends which was
about a two and a half hour drive this
way at least you were had something to
look at though as you drove when you
were driving from
um
I don't know a lot of that drive there's
not much to look at I mean once you get
through Orlando it's just all when you
when I was driving from Heidelberg
Heidelberg Mississippi down to New
Orleans
[__]
more than half of it is just like
Mississippi Badlands it's just dark
there's there's no lights at all here's
on those [__]
you're on the interstate not even any
other cars a lot of times
uh wait since you guys have reviewed
Chinatown you should review its spoof
Who Framed Roger Rabbit I have actually
been wanting to do Who Framed Roger
Rabbit for a really long time I remember
seeing that in the theater
um and the thing that I mainly remember
about seeing in the theater was that my
brother my youngest brother was when
what year did that movie came out 80
seven something like that I mean so my
youngest brother was like a baby because
he was like born in 1986.
and we took him like the whole family
went to see it and that part where judge
Doom like takes that little animated
shoe and puts him in the dip and he
melts which is pretty alarming for like
a kids movie I was just like holy [__]
um my little brother who was still in
diapers jumped out my mom's lap and
noped right out the [__] theater like
he just ran he just ran on his fat
little toddler legs and like ran out of
theater because it upset him so much
because he was so little it's like that
was like and I still remember that
that's like so funny but I still can't
believe they put that in a [__] kids
but I guess it's not technically a kid's
movie it kind of is but that's like
pretty upsetting to put it in a kid's
movie
but yeah I didn't really see any I
didn't really see any smoke but um from
the fire
however driving home from work today
like right when I left work at 4 30
um it [__] there was a huge downpour
in Daytona I don't know if it rained
here or not but it was um so I was on 92
and the rain was so bad that I couldn't
see anything so I just like I said just
kind of hoped that
no one was in front of me because I
couldn't see anything
you guys should see uh Jen Jen's looking
amazing right now
we're gonna do a photo shoot this
weekend too
all kinds of we got a whole wardrobe
coming project
half the [__] we got she hasn't even
worn it yet and got two more shipments
coming in
and we're gonna plug them again [__]
oh yeah I got this dress from Sheen and
then I haven't worn this one out yet and
we haven't done a photo shoot in this
one yet but I also have two more outfits
that I haven't worn yet that we haven't
done a photo shoot or videos and so
we're going to do that tomorrow you can
get a cool [__] goth dresses they're
for like 10 bucks
show them that dress yeah step there
look how awesome this dress is between
she's wearing a shrug over it right now
but
it didn't come with the shrug no I'm
just wearing that so it's not like to
slip it all blurry there you go yeah
yeah show them the size there you go
yeah see look at that bombshell we'll
see it right there damn
she got the address for ten dollars yeah
it was ten dollars and then like uh you
can get stockings for like two dollars
and fifty cents a pair
and uh accessories they're wigs for like
under twenty dollars they're nice wigs
and I talked to my friend um bill and I
said dude we've been hitting this she
and that because oh yeah she and that's
like a porn industry standard that's
that's where all the porn stars get
their [__] because they buy so much
stuff and only wear it once and I was
like no [__] they go oh yeah we've been
using Xi'an for [__] years yeah
because you're always going to need like
new tights and new like fishing at tops
and just you know [__] that is not
you know that you're only gonna wear
once or twice he said that and I said I
wonder if they got [__] sex toys that
I checked yeah they got a [__] ton I got
a [__] ton of them so I said okay that's
where they're getting all the props yeah
and it's um I would say that they're
kind of like direct prices they're not
retail that's like
what do you call it that that's uh
wholesale that's wholesale prices
and delivery is pretty prompt
you know 10 days maybe 15 days it's
worth it now some things you can get
they got a little electronics and [__]
like that in there too and little
like neon signs and knickknacks to dress
dress up rooms
decorations
some of the shit's real reasonable other
stuff you could probably get it for that
price on Amazon and if you have Amazon
Prime you get the next day
but when it comes to clothes clothing
also men's clothing I'm looking at the
men's clothing I've found ways to search
and find better [__] in there
I haven't seen any prices
on clothing that low I don't think
anybody can beat those prizes
Zach says uh
wearing um
wait a minute
doesn't wearing real complicated hairdos
like that hurt I always see them and I'm
like isn't that pulling on your scalp no
because
well some of this is real hair the bangs
are my real hair these braids are my
real hair and I have real hair in the
back but I basically just pull it up in
two little ponytails just like the back
of my hair and just kind of like make
little buns and then these are fake like
this so they just are two little
ponytails and you just like put them
over the thing so it's almost like just
a little hair thing that you put over
your little ponytails or your little
buns so it's not pulling it's not
pulling I was gonna wear a wig tonight
but that's too hot I feel it's too hot
you know what I mean yeah and I just it
looks good looks good like that plus I
just shaved recently shaved so it's good
plus I just got these earrings and I was
like oh I kind of wanted to wear these
earrings and if you have a wig on you
can't see them you know what I mean
because I got a couple pairs of earrings
I got some more stuff from Xi'an too I
got like a couple more necklaces and
couple more I didn't get any Wig wigs
but I got like some hair extensions like
some different colored braids that you
can snap in and [__] like that and I you
know and I got some shoes too Zach says
Jenny has legs Jenny's got [__]
awesome like real nice ones it's just
nobody ever sees them because I'm like a
newscaster you only see me from wouldn't
it be funny if it's like I stood up and
then just from the waist down it was
just like a broomstick like a puppet
she's she's been lifting her legs are
good
I wish I could I wish I was like good
enough at video editing that I could do
that like I stood up and then I just
like then it's like my bottom half it's
just like a popsicle stick
that would be super funny and now it's
like my bangs are pissing me off because
I brushed them all down
I had them perfectly straight
and then I sit in front of the camera
and I'm like now they're all [__] up
and crooked again I don't understand how
that happens
I don't understand it it's just kind of
like I cut them and they look perfectly
straight and I'm like beautiful and then
like the next day I brush them and then
they're all [__] crooked I don't
understand how I don't understand
and I don't understand how because I
only never go and get my hair done I
think the last time I went and had my
hair done or like cut or anything like
that at like an actual Salon I don't
even remember the last time that was
it's probably like 20 years ago or more
um you know because it's just it's
expensive and I can't really afford it
and I don't really do anything
complicated
so I mean I can cut my own bangs but
they're they always come out crooked
whatever
um Zach says I watched the thing about
how they make wigs for movies and it's
insane how often you can never tell even
if it just looks like the actor's
regular hair yeah I mean
some of the wigs I've seen some movies
with like some pretty tragic wigs in
there that like you could absolutely
tell was a wig but sometimes I'll see a
movie and then later on I'll find out
that that [__] was a wig and I'm just
like wow that was a really good one I
mean the ones I have obviously
you know I don't really care all that
much if they look realistic because you
know they're blue and green and [__]
like that so I'm just like duh obviously
it's a wig but
I don't know if I was gonna if I was
gonna do something where the hair had to
look realistic I would probably like
spend more money and get because don't
they have those ones with like lace
front or they have ones that are like
all complicated that look like
you know your scalp and all that but
it's just like anything else it's like
if you buy like a cheap ass
wig like I buy wigs that are only like
10 20 then yeah I mean they're not gonna
last that long I mean they look okay but
once you wear them a couple times
um you know and if you brush them like
you know the hair comes out and they
start getting thin and stuff like that
but I mean I've the ones I've got that I
probably paid like 20 bucks for like the
red one of the blue one and stuff I've
had those a while and I've worn them
like several times and they still look
pretty good I mean they still look okay
yeah and Zach said then again most of
them are also made from real hair too
which is upsetting to think about I
guess although don't people I mean it's
not like they're taking dead people's
hair or nothing like that right it's
still in their hair it's yeah it's just
like people that like donate hair they
don't donate the salad or Salad yeah
that's what I mean
it's usually Chinese girls hair
and uh they'll they'll be out they're
farm girls
and they'll let their hair grow real
long and cut it off and they'll give
them hundreds of dollars for it and
that's a lot of money they used to be
that way I don't know if it's still like
that but they were like Chinese farm
girls
they get like 100 bucks for their for a
head of their hair that's a lot of money
for them when it went over to the
Chinese economy versus what they were
what they were uh
uh Macon
and then they'd bleach it and [__]
dye it and turn it blonde or whatever it
didn't have to stay black
yeah you can do whatever do whatever you
want you know but it's or you know Asian
people
have thick hair
it takes dye real well and it lasts a
long time but it's not connected to a
head
but that [__] was expensive then it ends
up being the wigs for like a thousand
dollars it braid and everything I wonder
nowadays like
like the real high-end wigs that they
make out of real human hair it's like I
wonder what the market is for that like
how much they'd pay you for like
donating hair
probably not very much I imagine uh you
know what I mean uh a couple hundred
dollars probably depending on what your
hair is like but evidently they liked
Chinese hair
because it was just more durable
hmm and it was straight
I don't think anybody want my hair you
know just
because my hair is like
I have a lot of it like it's really
thick and like I said it just it comes
out like every time I brush it like it
comes out like in big clumps but I still
have it seems to never get any thinner
yeah but each individual strand is like
super super fine like baby hair yeah
Jen's got some weird hair I have weird
ass hair weird as [__] she's got down
[Laughter]
I'll trim her eyebrows and I'll be
sitting there trimming like that and
pulling it out with looking tweezers
like that
Believe It or Not people I got really
good like makeup and [__] eyebrow
skills and [__] I could probably been a
damn beautician yeah he's good at doing
my eyebrows because I can't do them
because I can't see all that well and
it's like I always get it and I've never
seen hair that small they're literally
like spider webs yeah and when you pull
them off there's no it doesn't look like
hair even when I have glasses on it
doesn't look like hair it looks like
fuzz yeah I've never seen hair that fine
and um
when I when I cut her hair when I shave
and stuff she has
normal hair but then even smaller hairs
along with it like down
I've never seen it I've never seen a
person with that
it's just I'm telling you I'm a mutant
yeah some kind of a redneck
honky Southern princess Jean that you
have it's something from up into down or
it might be motherland or it might be
from another planet up in Russia or some
[__] like that where it's down to
survive you know [__] extra cold
temperature
but uh I don't understand how she can do
it and she sheds all year round it'd be
long hairs all over the place I'm
[__] vacant good lord it's just yeah
and it's like my bathroom floor is just
I have to sweep it like all the time
because it's like there's just
constantly hair everywhere yeah but it
never did never on my head it's sick
it's still like thick which which is why
it's nice and it's like to keep it
shaved because when it's all grown out
because remember I had it all grown out
until recently and I said [__] this I'm
shaving it back off okay it's thick as
it is like and it's heavy it's heavy and
it's hot and it's just kind of like even
when it's short so I was just like [__]
it just shave it off it's such a pain
and it's straight
and it used to be red now it's just kind
of mousy proud you used it used to be a
well it's like yeah my hair is like it
goes ginger in the sun yeah my hair is
like um it's like a coppery red or like
a coppery orange is my natural hair
color okay it might still be that
although at this point it's probably
gray probably gray I haven't seen mine
it's probably great because I mean my
mom was gray by the time she was my age
it looks kind of just mousy brown color
I don't think you're gray but if you let
it grow there's probably straight gray
strips I imagine that it's probably gray
around like the yeah around here well
because when I do my roots and stuff
like that like I always get a little bit
of gray around there but you know what I
mean I'm 50 so you're right it's kind of
like
but yeah it's just and that's why too
like it being so fine that's why when I
was growing up
you know I had real long hair like down
on my butt and um I used to have to like
my mom or my grandma used to have to
just like just very carefully and I used
like that Johnson and Johnson no tears
baby shampoo and all that kind of [__]
and conditioner and stuff didn't work
um you so much is like fluff my hair
like that and it's just not
so then you have to just meticulously
like go through there and like comb all
the knots out and then like a bunch of
hair comes out it's like it's a
nightmare it's a nightmare my hair is a
[__] nightmare
which like I said it's much easier when
it's most of it is shaved off the top
part on the you know this is kind of
about this long and it's still kind of a
pain in the ass but it's better than
all of it it's I don't really know what
to do with it
I wish I look good with no hair like I
wish I looked good bald like you do
but I don't think I look good bald
I've never been bald yeah but I just
suspect that I would not look good bald
I don't know you'd have to try I mean I
feel like I look like a big fan turn
your head sideways so they can see I
think she looks good with her head
shaved on the sides and it's shaved on
the sides in the back all over it she
just has a top
yeah
she just has a top yeah
there's no hair back here
but but it's a lot like the top part of
it it's just the crown but it's like
it's about this long top and bangs yeah
okay up guy said I'm 61 with a silver
fox gray and black
[Laughter]
yeah I'm sure I don't know what color my
actual hair is now it is probably still
reddish I imagine but because I don't
let it ever as soon as like the roots
start to grow out and look gray I'm just
like whooping I just like put [__]
more dye on there
uh Zach says I hate my eyebrows they're
thin and asymmetrical and don't move
I have big okay for a long time if
you've watched this show for like a
really long time
probably for like 10 years I think it
was probably like 10 or 11 years ago I
was so sick of dealing with my stupid
eyebrows that I was like [__] it I'm
just like she's gonna shave them off and
then I just like draw them back on yeah
and so I did that for a really long time
and then after all I was like you know
what it's just probably like a year ago
I said I'm gonna grow my eyebrows back
and now I'm kind of like thinking about
Shameless yeah
those little small pictures of you and I
actually would was thinking I missed
those eyebrows that were painted on
because you did you did them differently
all the time yeah yeah you could do
different all kinds of you could do like
normal [__] or you could like put them
way up here you could do all kind of
crazy some of the goth [__] real high
ones that you did look really cool but
just the ones you were wearing the
little stick on forehead jewelry and
stuff and the [__] wigs you had it
looked real good yeah if you want to do
it just do it
it's easy you know I mean and at the
work that you're at you don't have to
have eyebrows if you don't want to
they're not gonna say anything to you I
mean I always like think I look weird
without any eyebrows that's kind of why
I decided to grow them back because I
said oh well in case I don't feel like
putting makeup on or don't put feel like
putting much makeup on if you don't have
eyebrows I always feel obligated to like
kind of draw the eyebrows on because
everybody's just kind of like you look
kind of weird like without any eyebrows
so I always kind of feel like drawing
them on but but the the flip side of
that is if you have regular eyebrows you
gotta [__] pluck them all the time
yeah pluck them like a chicken it's
called tweeze Jen you don't pluck look
you know what though um
um Tiff my first wife she didn't have
any eyebrows
she would work every day but she would
she would get she had a system to get
eyebrows on in like two seconds she just
took the pencil and [__] went boom
boom boom made dots and then connected
the dots and I just saw her do it it was
like [__] you ever seen that no that's
how I used to take a pencil put your
finger on one one part of it to measure
it
yeah you just you would just go like
yeah like right there right there right
there that's how you yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's I did that's what I said you run
out and and they look good she could do
it in [__] five seconds yeah you get
used to doing it right for a while
that way I don't have to tweeze them
every couple weeks well [__] every week
every week yeah because honestly I was
just looking at them today because I was
putting my makeup on and I was like [__]
man they need to be tweezed again
like and you just did them yeah a few a
few days ago yeah shave that [__] it's
like see I don't know man I'm gonna be
out there
yeah Chinese woman sitting there yeah
you just did it last Saturday or Sunday
I think like before we did the yeah
before we did the um
photo shoots and all of that yeah just
shave them off you get more looks that
way you can do different styles yeah you
know for the photo shoots so you can
change whatever eyebrow you have
yeah it is like a lot more it's a lot
more versatile
for sure Jason S says make a wig out of
your own hair and you can shave your
head all the time there's too many cheap
wigs
too many cheap wigs out there I have so
many wigs you guys I don't even realize
I didn't even realize like how many
because I have a bunch that I don't even
like remember that I don't Sheen's got
some [__] Thirty thirty dollar 25 to
30 rage 35 range [__] wigs that are
extravagant as [__] have you seen those
things which ones are you talking they
look like some other damn cosplay for
anime oh yeah yeah yeah I mean they look
great man I mean they have those on
Amazon yeah I mean you could really do
anything with it other than dress up as
some character that it's it's meant to
look like some character
but I'm just amazed how much you could
get for 35 dollars
yeah
they got a [__] ton of [__] wigs man
going
you know 60s looking wigs from the 19
you know just old out of date styles
that still look cool
you know 60s bobs
well I got that one that's like a bob
that you took you took some pictures of
me like and we took some video last
weekend of me they got some cool they
got some cool black girl wigs [__]
cornrows and [__]
um big plaits and [__] big long braids
although they look cool I have thought
about dreading dreads yeah but yeah you
have to [__] grow a lot of hair out
to dread that's yeah and then you're
stuck with that look yeah because then
that's the only thing that gives me
pause about it it's like I think it
would look good but yeah if you decide
you don't like it you have to basically
cut everything off they got dread wigs
out there they do I know just get that
well see that's what I figured I was
like well if I just get a bunch of like
wigs and hair extensions and stuff that
I don't really have to like worry too
much about my regular hair looks like
because I can just like if we have if
you start getting into this [__]
especially when [__] business starts
rolling on our other project if we need
room we can put up [__] wig stands
and [__] over in the dam
even in the uh even in the gym if we
have to yeah I definitely because I have
I got them on um Amazon a long time ago
but they're just like little wig stands
they're just plastic you know they're
like round like a little head and then
it's got like a little stand on it but
it's just I didn't have any room like to
put them in the closet I had them
standing up in there but then you know
sometimes we would do the show and you
would run in there and get a wig and
just knock them all over yeah like so
they all just went all over the floor we
need a wig place so I do have a bunch of
wig stands yeah
um but and I have ones that hang up too
that like hang in a closet that have
like a head but for right now there's a
lot of room out in this living room
right here if you want if you wanted to
start using that but we have to get like
things like uh
coat racks you know if you want to hang
up clothes or costumes and [__] see that
would be good I could use that because I
have this closet here but it's like it's
crammed full of stuff and it's just like
a pain in the ass there's shoes piled up
there's wigs okay look look all kinds of
[__] right there we can put right in
this area yeah we put one of those big
dressers not a dresser what do you call
them like a
where they got coat stands or no what do
they call a thing where where it opens
up and you can actually hang like a
wardrobe a wardrobe a big wardrobe right
there that would actually be pretty
useful I think yeah and there's that's
dead space right there and a big
wardrobe yeah well because that's where
my couch was but then you took the couch
and put it in your man cave it makes
more sense in there anyway it does yeah
I wasn't really using it you weren't
using it I was gonna use it like I
brought it in here for I was like oh
it'd be nice to have like a little
seating area over there we could sit and
read or whatever but I just I never used
it yeah look at that spot Jen yeah
there's nothing just put a wardrobe
there yeah maybe I should yeah we'll see
well and then just yesterday we went to
um Dollar General yeah and got uh it's
just like a little storage Cube thing to
put all the dildos on yeah so we have
like a dildo stand to go like in the
back of the it will light it up from the
inside yeah and I was looking at the
stream mate show for the streammate show
yeah because we because we had like we
bought some like some cool looking sex
toys like that are all like weird colors
and [__] right like that are all
monstery show it to them so I was like
does that then come off there
no
yeah
I'll just pick it up
okay but you're yeah good luck with that
one where is it good luck with that
you're gonna knock everything over and
pull it out or something you can't see
it see those blue blue things right
there making everybody that's them
here's the mirror
there's not enough light to see it but
that's what we're talking about
yeah we got a little thing to put them
on and I was thinking I was looking on
Sheen today and I was looking for some
of those um look at that I got you the
perfect spots right where he belongs
I'll put Spock Right Where You belongs
um I was looking at some of those little
neon lights and everything I liked the
Cherry ones they had like a bat like a
little neon bat they had a moon that was
pretty yeah yeah it was like red you saw
that but here was the thing I didn't I
put one in the cart I think it was only
like six dollars or something
but I didn't buy it because I was like
wait does it have a stand or do you have
to like hang it because it didn't look
like it was just like freestanding
um I liked the moon one okay yeah but I
don't think it had a stand no it's
probably not on the wall I think you
could just like hang it from a nail or
some [__] like that yeah they have a lot
of those so they're like six bucks each
yeah they were like six or seven dollars
yeah I saw the bat yeah and they and
they had different colors they had a
pink one and a purple one and [__] like
that some were just like women's legs
yeah I saw that one too high heels and
they had lips lips yeah Hearts yeah
Hearts [__] like that so we wanted to
get some stuff because like I said when
we start doing the um the live streams
we kind of want some exciting [__] like
in the background like some lights and
some cool [__] to look at so I gotta set
up stream eight this weekend I was like
it's funny because
so we've been because if you've been
here like we've been having a [__] of a
time like getting on only fans like you
have I had to send in
um you know you have to send in a
picture of your ID and like a picture of
yourself with your ID and it's just like
it the picture of the ID was just like
never good enough even I was just like I
scanned it I took a picture of it it was
like highest resolution that I had blah
blah and I said it like a billion times
and it was just never good enough even
though I'm like duh you can read it I'm
just like you guys are just being dick
dicks or whatever and then they were
like oh well you don't have enough
social media you know this that and the
other I was like and I was just like
should I just keep sending them the same
[__] over and over until you know just
like a war of attrition until they just
get sick of me and just like okay fine
[__] just just do it but then we were
thinking why don't we just like go to
streamate and just like we'll start
doing that you can sell videos on there
too as far as I'm aware and it's like
then later we can maybe start the only
fans thing because they're being real
buttholes about
um
about like not having enough social
media or something like that I don't
really know what their problem is and
like I said they keep saying my ID
picture isn't clear enough even though
I'm not really sure how I can make it
any clearer but um so yeah so we were
gonna start doing that so I started
watching like just on my lunch hours I'm
sitting in the car like in the parking
lot of like where I work
so I just go to stream mate and I don't
have an account on there yet
but I'm just like going around randomly
watching I'm just like whoever is on
live you know at that time of day and
it's all it's people all over the world
so it's not weird that like people are
on at noon or whatever and one thing
that I noticed I watched some of the
single girl cams I watched some of the
um the couple cams and like some of the
other stuff and I'm like man ninety
percent of the people that I and I just
picked like random ass people and I was
like 90 of the people in there boring as
[__] they're not doing anything yeah
they're not even talking well yeah
that's what I mean and like I mean yeah
they're not supposed to I mean you can
do whatever you want on there it's your
thing but it's like most of the time
they're just
um you know waiting for people to like
tip them to like you know to get them to
do something or like go in their gold
show or whatever but it's like I would
think that you would want people to like
you know people just wandered into your
room like you would be engaging yeah so
they would stay and like tip you and
stuff but every single one that I
clicked on people were just like sitting
there they weren't knitting they weren't
talking one girl was knitting I went in
one time there was a girl laying a [__]
to sleep
they were just like instead of like
staring off into space they're like
looking at their phone even when it was
like more than one person because I saw
what I saw several that were like
couples I saw one that was like a girl
and two guys and they were just like you
know they're all naked and they're all
just like sitting there they're not
doing anything they're not talking to
anybody they're not part of the problem
is um Colombia Latin America
they're in this in our same time zones
they don't speak English and there's a
lot of them on there
um so the they're trying to get I guess
American customers
but the Amer they can't really interact
because they can't they can't speak
English
so they just sit there saying nothing
back when I was checking that site out
before you know we decided to do it
there was a girl in Germany goth chick
in Germany had a big old [__]
pentacle [__] tattooed across their
chest and she was [__] cool and all
she did was just talk and talk and talk
and she had 30 guys in that room tips
right and she they would give her tips
just to flash and [__] because you can
Flash
um but you can't do anything
um you can't do anything like
penetration or anything in public right
all that other [__] is in private so she
was just sitting there getting one and
five dollar tips
just dudes [__] asking her to flash
and talking to guys yeah and then our
next go hold on I'll be back and then
she'd be gone for two or three minutes
because she's helping some dude jerk off
and then she's back and all the dudes
are waiting for it yeah
I mean just I'm looking at it going like
like I you know it I I was looking at
from a point of view it's like say I'm a
straight dude
and I'm like looking for somebody that's
like but I'm clicking on all of these
and I'm like no one's doing anything
interesting like nobody is interacting
with anybody everyone's just kind of
like sitting there looking bored and
like staring off into space or like I
said I saw one girl she was legit
knitting yeah like and she was with her
boyfriend they weren't even talking to
each other yeah which I said that to me
like seemed like that would be a good
um one of the benefits of like doing it
as a couple is that like if there's
nobody in your room or no one's
interacting with you you can at least
talk to each other and you know then you
so you'll look like active like you're
doing something so that will get more
people engaged but they weren't even
doing that that German girl was in there
talking about music when I first went in
and I and I asked her if she if she knew
what Neo folk was and then she goes oh
yeah I listened to death in tune and
[__] current 93. the whole thing and
then other guys in the comments because
a lot of them were goth too they were
just they were talking then they started
talking about the Neo folks scene and
then she goes hold on I'll be right back
she's gone
yeah to flash your titties and suck on
some kind of dildo or something else
then she's back three minutes later okay
back
that dude leaves yeah because they can
talk in private or in public
so
but dudes were she had about 30 guys in
there just talking to her and I was I
was like man Jenny be great at this
I was like Jenny be great at this
[__] you know just because she can
talk
and there they talk they were talking
about stuff they weren't just you know
talking about your ass or anything they
were talking about stuff
well that's one thing and I and a lot of
um you know when I was watching a bunch
of different women that did this for a
living and that's what a lot of them
said they're like 90 of the time you're
not even talking about anything sexual
people just want you to like talk to
them about like whatever they're just
lonely they got credit cards right so
it's like therapy dudes in there you
know then they want a few minutes alone
yeah that's all and then they're
regulars they come back
we're going to do it kind of as a couple
which I could help you know what I mean
[__]
and some dudes are cool with that other
other it's going to chase other guys
away a lot of guys don't want any other
dude around they want like a girlfriend
experience and you know [__] um Jenny
can go [__] solo if she wants so
certain times it doesn't [__] matter
to me it's because it's it's fantasy and
it's nothing more than
any other Stage production
so
it's not sex you know what I mean it's
it's it's an act there's nobody here
it's just me and her yeah that's what I
mean that's what appeals to me about it
is that you can do all this [__] but it
doesn't really I mean like I said
there's nobody in the room with you yeah
it's not like it's all it's all fantasy
yeah they're they could be halfway
around the world it's the same
relationship we have with y'all
it's just a different element but we
talked to you guys and we remember you
and [__] Zach I talked to Zach
offline [__] talk to talk to [__]
murder hornets and bee's nest and
[__] xanada you know so and it's the
same thing with those girls on stream
mates some of them they know some of
them know these guys
you know
they had one girl who went to
one of her biggest followers son's
graduation the the wife was there that's
some weird [__] but that's but they and
the dude would not
would not jerk to the [__] girl he
had known her too long he respected her
yeah she was like his buddy and she he'd
tip her just and they would just talk
see that's cool though yeah it's just a
different interaction that's all I'm not
worried it's a different kind of show
I'm not worried about it it's not
like I said I kind of thought of it like
the same pretty much the same as this
show yeah except with an extra element
it can be x-rated yeah that's the that's
the only difference and to me that's not
really that big if we could do that here
we would
well we can't do it that's what I was
thinking I was like do it on YouTube was
it yeah like we can't do it there have
been times where I wanted to [__] do
some [__]
especially like when you're real drunken
yeah or like [__] really Juiced up on
some kind of [__] test or if you guys
are if you guys are long enough if
you've watched this show long enough
when I was [__] drunk and on a bunch
of hormones I'm basically trying to dry
hump her off I wasn't making that up
she's like stop it stop it
why why I become like a 15 year old why
yeah why can't I get any you're so emo
Tom yeah I was like that yeah
but you know but yeah see if you're on
streamate then you don't have to you can
just do it you can just do it because
it's okay yeah you just can't do it you
just gotta go private yeah you just say
okay hey everybody come in the room with
us and give us the money and then you
could actually do a free show
they have that too well I did notice
that
um just from a cursory Glimpse like
through the [__] some people were nobody
was doing anything like super hardcore
but a lot of people were sitting around
naked yeah um you can be nude you just
can't do anything sexual yeah it can be
R-rated it can't be x-rated basically I
did see one that was like a BJ but you
couldn't see it was basically you just
saw her ass
like they had it they're not doing
anything though they're similar right
they're like faking it and another thing
is I saw one girl blowing a big old
rubber dick
and they can do that in public because
that's not real because that's not a
real dig yeah even though it was one of
the mechanical kinds that could shoot
[__] all over and they were tapping her
and she was doing that on stream big not
ChatterBait stream bait so that the
rules evidently say you can do that
there in public as long as it's not a
real day as long as it's not real
right yeah because they have those fake
ones that are like [__] yeah and behind
her she had a wheel it was spinning on
her on her motor with about six of them
they were all numbered different dicks
it was a wheel of dicks another Wheel of
Fortune
she had that behind we need to get a
wheelie decks back there
I like it I like Zach wouldn't you love
to have a wheel of dicks I mean if
you've got a wheel of dicks
where can we get a wheel of decks well I
just looked like she made it well yeah
like I could make that I could make
something like that yeah well that would
be kind of cool because it would just be
like I'm G just from like a like a
Showbiz kind of standpoint you could do
it just like Wheel of Fortune but you
could have like different colored um
like sections on the wheel and you could
like stick a dildo like on each one it
had different numbers one or six and
they were spinning and then I guess guys
were spinning a a
some kind of random number generator
right yeah and yeah and then she had it
whatever the number landed on that was
the one she had to grab you had to spend
a certain amount of money to get to spin
the wheel
Zach said I feel semi-compelled to watch
the other show but I still think it'd be
too weird no I don't know I don't
I understand no it's gonna have a lot of
humor in it I would understand if people
would think it was weird but I don't
really I don't think it's weird and Tom
doesn't think it's no we come from a
fetish background and everything like I
said it's not it's not really that big a
deal to us so it's like
exactly exactly like I can't believe my
favorite people are whoring themselves
out and I was like I guess you don't
really know us
because
me and Jenna been together [__] 13
years and half that time we were [__]
going to like [__] fetish clubs and
[__] you know all kinds of [__]
weird [__] was going on we maybe we
weren't doing anything
but we just kind of came from that
environment you know we
sex wasn't really a big deal for us it
was yeah yeah you know whatever it was
just the kind of thought it was funny
yeah you know you know
it's just another thing yeah
that happens
sometimes it happens sometimes it
depends on who you are sometimes it
happens with other people that are
around you know if you've had enough
drinks or whatever and then you know
there's that kind of [__] I mean there
was some [__] going on at [__]
Southern Nights that's what it was
happening on stage
two yeah so and that was a it was a drag
bar on normal nights but we had a goth
night going there yeah it was a goth
fetish night yeah it was called Escape
yeah it's called Escape you would love
you would have loved that [__] Zach that
place was like a [__] gay Paradise
man it's like it looked like such a nice
place I think it's still there at the
club is still there it's like it looked
like Tiki theme kind of a little bit you
kind of yeah and you could go in they
had out or like classy Miami but like a
tiki bar outside yeah you go outside
it's like tiki bars and [__] they
were uh
weren't there uh fountains with lights
and [__] in there or was it just Gardens
with lights I thought there might have
been a fan yeah it was like a little
garden like area like a little garden
patio back there it was actually really
nice like the patio they did a nice job
like that then there was a theater in
there and a couple dance like with a
stage and everything like with curtains
yeah yeah
and uh place was [__] Wild
I got to go up on stage and
um [__] a girl in the ass with a with a
blow up dick yeah yeah that's right
that's right and then I had to go up
there and dig through a [__] litter
box
for cat [__] with your mouth with my
mouth
fake it was not
uh it was [__] Rice Krispies with
[__] chocolate pudding in it yeah it
had to dig through there to get a prize
they were like Tootsie Rolls tootsie
rolls and chocolate pudding yeah [__]
was all over me did that on stage I got
pictures of that somewhere yeah
because I was like oh my God and the
prize I got was porn yeah they gave us
we got something like and it wasn't real
good porn it was kind of like second
rate [__] it was kind of like some some
ladies that had didn't they didn't they
have like some sports [__] on and I was
like that's not really no there was only
one good porn star on it and that was
Katrina she was yeah she was known from
the 90s like we won some other [__] out
there early 2000s Katrina was up I
remember we won well we won some
handcuffs there one time like some pink
ones and we won yeah didn't we win like
a vibrating egg or something yeah
something like that I don't remember
it's real bad sex toys yeah and I was
like I don't remember where it is but
yeah they used to do like um
like a game show yeah basically like
every every every night they would do
like exactly talking about the gay
Paradise where he's at what's it called
now Greg's AKA our place okay yeah
the O in the logo is a toilet lid yeah
oh okay so so I immediately know it
Southern Nights was a [__] a fun Club
like I said each night was a different
theme we were going there on the on the
goth theme but it was the same staff
they were all gay guys so I can run the
staff they were great
um you'd have [__] drag queens in
there I think some of them were staffed
too yeah yeah and then um
across the street was a cheap motel so
you knew what was going on there yeah
like one of those pay by the hour yeah
yeah and then uh but it was like some
[__] Gavin Friday [__] level uh
gay Paradise [__] uh you utilized
exact it's funny because like I said I
think it's still there yeah and it looks
like nothing from the outside yeah it's
just like that it's not in a part of
town where there's other clubs it's just
kind of like it's by an overpass yeah
there's like across the street there's
like a cheap motel there's like some
insurance offices and [__] that are
either closed obviously and it's just
like and it's just sitting there like in
a parking lot it looks kind of crappy
from the outside it looks kind of like a
dump but like the inside is like really
really it was decked out yeah
and uh you know bad [__] was going on in
their naughty [__] because we were doing
naughty [__] in it the straight people
the God people were doing naughty [__]
so I could imagine that the gays were
doing crazy [__] well I kind of feel
like the goth scene and the gay scene
are kind of like kind of similar and
similar like and a Jace there's a lot of
overlap it's just kind of like the god
scene in The Fetish scene not everybody
that's into goth is into fetish stuff
right but you go to a fetish party and
it's gonna be like 60 70 80 yeah yeah
and a lot of them aren't super super
into fetish stuff it's just some of it's
just Aesthetics but yeah the the
official sexual orientation of the goth
scene is fetish whether or not they're
actually into it or not that's just
that's just that's just the banner that
they will Wave It's kind of fetishy
yeah like people are aware of the [__]
and everything and some of them were
into like light BDSM and [__] like that
I don't know if anybody's like well I
was gonna say I don't know if we know
some but when yeah we do know some
people that are like really into it Ryan
and Becky in the sense that they like
every time there's a fetish uh
convention like they're right at that
[__] like they go like several times a
year
yeah yeah they want to really admit it
though yeah yeah that actually go to all
that stuff and everything like that like
I've been to ones like that I've been to
ones in Fort Lauderdale and all that
kind of stuff but you know I'm not I'm
kind of like half into it and like half
not I'm not like super hardcore about it
but yeah
and you know if you go to the castle in
Tampa their whole bottom floor well not
the whole bottom floor but like half of
the bottom floor is the dungeon they
built a whole dungeon and that's Spanish
[__] well there was some good [__] going
on in there yeah so like all around the
periphery
on one side is all cages so you can like
go in the cages and then like along the
back wall is you know like uh shackles
and [__] like on the walls so you can do
that and then in the middle is like all
couches like you know little pits with
yeah couches you can look at the castle
in Tampa you can you can Google that
so they have big huge fetish parts and
Southern Nights you can Google that too
and I think it's nights with a K right
no it is with an end yeah it's just
night slick regularly yeah okay and
that's uh night like night time it's in
Orlando Southern Nights in Orlando yeah
yeah and there might be some interior
shots of the place yeah had a great had
a great dance floor great great bars uh
great outdoor bars and it's too hot now
but
for the outdoor bars but yeah
it's nice out there though yeah yeah it
is
you can smoke out there there's back
when we're smoking yeah that was that's
how long ago and then last time we went
there I think it's still open I'm not
actually sure but
yeah they're talking about kitty litter
box cake well it's funny because when we
went to that party and they had the
whole that was part of the game show and
that well we knew um our friend Dustin
uh was one of the guys that ran the game
show
like because he was one of the ones that
put together the night he was like one
of the guys that did it and uh the other
guy his name was Mike he actually died a
couple years ago I think he OD'd but um
so they would
so they would do like a game show every
week and they would like up the stakes
like every week so it's like you always
had to do like kind of embarrassing or
like really disgusting things and
sometimes like you'd win good [__] like
you'd win like a 50 bar tab or something
because I think I won one of those one
time but they would always like think of
like bro [__] to do so like the litter
box thing I really wanted Tom to go up
there and do it because he had never
heard of like a litter box cake before
and I said I thought that's like a big
thing right I thought everybody knew
like what a litter box it's kind of like
um you know that other cake where you
put it in like a bucket and it looks
like dirt and then you put like gummy
worms in it and [__] like that I was
like it's kind of like that but it's
like a litter box and it's just you know
Rice Krispie treats and you put like you
melt some
uh you know what do you call them
Tootsie Rolls in there so it looks like
cat turds and then you put you make a
cake out of it he thought I was making
it up until I went like Googled it I'm
like look there's a million it's a thing
like he didn't believe me I was like no
it's a thing so he had to go up there so
I do have some pictures of him
sticking his face in a in a litter box
yeah the litter box with I gotta find
those they're on Facebook somewhere but
it's like it's really old I got him that
was like years ago I got pictures of it
yeah you want me to show the pictures I
mean if you could find them oh yeah
they're they're on my Facebook oh okay
yeah they're probably on my Facebook too
but I'm not gonna I can't find that
Tammy said like a while back she said
you don't know we might be jerking off
to you guys all the time
it's all right that's what I mean and
it's just like not to be weird it's like
we know you know we know you guys it's
okay like we're not worried about it
don't be weird about it you know like
you don't have to watch it I'm not
saying that anybody has to watch it but
I think that it's gonna be two different
scenes mostly so it probably is but I
kind of picture it being
mostly like this
but more that's kind of how I picture it
going it might not go like that we'll
see
well we got to play it by ear because
that that's a very fluid
[__] situation over there yeah I've
watched how they're doing it and those
girls were just very fluid playing it by
ear
it depends on who was in that room
that's well yeah and that's kind of the
way I mean that's kind of the way we do
this show yeah you're just they're just
you're interacting with whoever is and
they're just [__] sensing who's in
the crowd and playing to the crowd which
is just second nature for me and Jan
actually well we've been doing this a
long time yeah I was trained after you
know [__] um and I was just amazed
how
much Jenny picked up on going live on
stage and working off the Synergy of the
stage
just without any training she just did
it on her own because I guess it's
second nature for a lot of people
well not a lot of people it would would
have been something you need to train
them for a long time ago
now that there is such a thing as
YouTube and streaming
a civilian that's what I'm going to call
them a civilian can pick it up in a
couple shows that's not the way it used
to be used to be to get that feeling you
had to be on a stage in front of a live
audience you don't need that anymore
well now you have to think that you know
people younger than us have grown up
filming everything yeah filming
themselves and it's like so there it's
not they don't have stage fright right
it's not weird to them to be like
they'll just like [__] you know
they're like yeah we're just
broadcasting everything yeah so it's
like they don't it doesn't bother them
the same way that it maybe would have
bothered us awesome like older people
right I mean they were back in the day
people would freeze if you put a camera
on them
yeah well it's weird and I think I've
said this before but you know for a long
time oh yeah there's one of the pictures
that's me digging
I was on stage in front of him with your
face in it too but yeah yeah I got it
it's the next one oh okay you got your
face in there yeah because I know I took
some because I was like oh my God I was
back when I had hair I was like this is
too [__] face in there trying to get
the damn Tootsie Rolls it was supposed
to be like a cat turds yeah yeah did you
won right did you win yeah one yeah
because I thought we got a prize I think
I got more
photos of that of when they when they
gave me the prize I think I got that oh
yeah maybe I think I got that I think
that was the same night that I was like
sticking that thing in that girl's butt
yeah I think so yeah
and I think she had a bunch of like
shaving cream on her butt or something
too if I remember it was a long time ago
but um and I was probably a little
inebriated I think the whole studio was
well yeah everyone was very interested
that was just that was what you did you
just went there and got it yeah
blasted this wasn't 100 this was not in
public we know everybody
all the hundreds of people that's
actually the street that was actually
the stage where it was happening at
Southern Nights oh yeah that's right
yeah they won't focus
that was the stage
and the crowd and like I said yeah and
they had that that that's right they had
that wheel back there yeah where they
were spoon and they always and they'd
always like make you like drink gross
stuff and yeah [__] like that
and you can volunteer like they didn't
have to
but if it well because I think for the
for the cat turd thing I think I
volunteered you
or or I caught Destin's eye I'm just
like yeah
I think if I remember correctly but
we just saw Destin
look that's Southern the other day
we hadn't seen him in a lot of Southern
Nights right there yeah that's right
that was a while back that's the club
that was that's the Southern Nights
can't really see yeah
and I got that big [__] ring back
there
John Gore said I've never watched people
I know having sex it had weird me out
but that's just me
not that I know Jenny and Tom but the
parasocial thing I mean I feel like we
know you guys though and like I said I
don't
yeah more of me eat now the cat bucks oh
no there's there's Destiny back there on
the microphone [__] egging me on and
the crowds off yeah
I think I did voluntary friends because
I was like come on that's too [__]
funny yeah he got right in there I mean
he was he was a trooper I was surprised
because I think he was just like oh [__]
I don't want to do that and I was like
please it's like come on that'd be so
funny
and he did he did it yeah
Camp guy said
um contestants must without using their
hands pick up a jumbo green olive off a
large block of ice in their butt cheeks
and race around an obstacle course loser
has to eat the Winner's Olive it was
yeah it was [__] like that I mean I
don't think it was anything quite that
elaborate but it was things along those
lines you know what I mean that you had
to do
I remember one one time didn't they do
something where it's like there was like
a big bucket full of hot dogs or
something and you had to like go and
leaky bobbing for hot dogs and then you
had to like [__] pick it out with
your hands not your butt cheeks I don't
think but I don't remember I don't
remember they took Dustin's little
friend what was his name uh
little twinkie guy
um oh [__] what was that dude's name
Ryan no no Brian no he had the white the
white yeah the white hair yeah I know
who you're talking about what the [__]
was that motherfucker's name it had him
in some kind of machine where it was
jizz was porn they said it was jizz oh
that's right it was pictures yeah yeah
fake jizz porn yeah he was like it was
like a tank or something tank is sort of
what was that guy's name God damn all
they did was torture that guy
[Laughter]
but yeah well he was fun he was the
greatest he was the gayest straight guy
I ever knew yeah yeah you would swear to
God he was gay he wasn't straight yeah
but uh
he looked like uh like the Lost member
of Duran Duran slightly he did kind of
kind of yeah
what was that yeah I had forgotten about
the jizz tank yeah the jizz tank what
was that guy's name man I haven't seen
him forever
yeah like I said moved away well they
all did I mean Destin moved away but
Norwegian L.A now I think well we just
saw Destin though the other he was back
he didn't move back did he you just
visit we saw him at mannequins like a
couple weeks ago we were like holy [__]
man where have you been we haven't seen
him in like [__] years he's in the LA
scene now
he was talking about moving back though
yeah yeah
you just said it cost so much money to
do anything there
yeah I get that yeah I mean you know
costs a lot of money to do [__]
everywhere but I told him I said man
this place is right for you to come back
it's like I'm thinking about it
this [__] man Destin was great at
[__] showing it one of the greatest
[__] club nights
that we in in this area Orlando I mean
he was into that like he was really good
at coming up with he was a great host
yeah and he would always do like he host
all the games too because not only would
they do the game show that was like at
the you know the apex of the night they
would do the big game show and everybody
would go in the theater and watch it and
like you could participate in the games
and stuff but prior to that like he
always came up with like a different
theme like every single week you're very
creative so yeah it was all so it every
single time they did it was like a
different theme I remember doing I'm
trying to remember some of the themes
they did the one that I remember was
like um
like evil Disney because I was uh I was
scary Poppins for that but like some and
people did they did it once a month so
people would do like really elaborate
costumes because you had all month you
know they would announce the theme you
know like a couple weeks in advance
someone has tipped us thank you very
much Zach thanks Zach the other gay
Paradise here is Club Indy which is a
bath house okay but it's super nice they
got a gym pool sauna all used for
exactly what you imagine
that's cool I'm glad that the bath house
subculture is still going strong I feel
like that was kind of like a 70s thing
but as far as I know I was watching Dan
Bell I can't understand how you horse
can do that I was watching Dan Bell like
his live stream last Saturday if you
don't know like Dan Bell does a live
stream usually every Saturday not always
but um and he drives around Baltimore
and just like you know shoots the [__]
whatever and they're opening a bath
house like a new bath because Dan Bell
is gay too and um and they're opening a
Bath House in Baltimore too like it's
supposed to be like really nice and I
was like for some reason like I knew
they were still around but I was like I
thought the like the big Heyday of them
was like the 70s the age scare [__]
that's what I mean I thought that it put
but I think maybe I mean it didn't
really disappear though did it it just
kind of like pushed it Forward right
into the ground I guess and you just
have to be like more careful that's all
yeah I don't think it stopped anybody
from doing anything it doesn't seem like
you just had to be more careful that's
all so
just like anything else it's
but you know [__] just kind of it
doesn't go away it just goes underground
Jack how easy is it to get laid in a
place like that you just go I'm I'm
gonna show up where all these [__]
[__] men are and I'm a [__] we're
all [__] together and [__] it how easy
is it together all these horror man how
easy is it to actually hook up I've
always wondered that
what a curious you're gonna go down no
like check it out no yeah
you know that wouldn't be the same as
going to a [__] straight Singles Club
because you got to fight for it you know
what I'm talking about and you got to
compete against the other guys there and
uh uh
and you you probably not gonna get laid
right there you know what I mean I'm
trying to think there is no straight
equivalent to that
a nudist cap maybe not but not really
because noodles camps are not really
yeah
I always had the perception like I you
know I don't know that much about like
the subculture even though there is a
nudist beach not far from here you know
that right the the closest equivalent
will be that thing that [__] my ex
and Tony invited us to later and told us
about oh right right it's called Uh
Secrets yeah [__] my ex-girlfriend
who's who's also a friend of Jan's
and the guy hooked her hooked her up
with once we broke up Tony who's another
good friend of mine their friends are
ours yeah they're married they're
married they're married they've been
married you know I've shown them before
Tony and later
they're real nice couple yeah they're
just friends of ours and really she's my
ex but
didn't mean anything to us you know what
I mean [__]
she's goth girl so we're just not
jealous
I love her yeah they're they're friends
you know
um they invited us to go to this place
called Secrets which is a club A
couple's Club
that's merged with a with like a
swingers Hotel swingers Hotel yeah they
go there every Saturday they go there
every Saturday you got to be a member
it's not open to the public
he's giving me all kinds of because you
need to come come hang out with us come
back you know horn dogs like oh you want
to swap you know that's what that's what
he wants he wants to swap
please show me all kinds of pictures
because they take pictures in there
yeah they got some fine girls in there
[__] couples and [__] elata and
[__] another couple and this and that
and [__] just getting it on I can't
show the pictures I got it well
obviously they got mirrors on the
ceilings it looks like a [__]
Disneyland hotel look I love hotels like
the one from the Poconos like the one
with the Poconos does it have
heart-shaped tub because I might you
want me to show it to you
well you showed me some pictures from me
but I didn't really I didn't get a good
I didn't get a good look at the room you
just kind of showed me like the pictures
of other people which I was like yeah
okay yeah
let me see
Hugo said I worked on a porn Space movie
once we rented two space suits for the
porn stars and some props it was fun oh
my God space porn hold on let me put it
this way oh okay oh yeah we definitely
can't show that picture no
that's that's the mirror in the ceiling
oh okay I got you look at latest booty
[__] huge but you could I could
actually show that's not here she's not
she's not nude I can show that huge gosh
oh no when you see that [__] in person
they're not nudes so I can show that
okay well I'm still gonna probably yeah
that's the mirror in the ceiling
right there sorry I just thought it yeah
oh that was a show that way I thought of
that Jam song but that's right this is
mirror in the bathroom this is also not
nude I can show that one that's not nude
uh that's some chick that they hung up
I can't really show that because I have
permission with her I was gonna say yeah
yeah Tony and Elena don't care
that's a later
well it's just white yeah that's what
you can't really see it you can't see it
I still can't see it that's me in a
later
back before I met Jim that was an old
picture oh look at [__] time I know
that's a lady in Japan actually
and she is my age yeah she's your age
yeah I think she's the same age as me
yeah that's a good picture of her yeah
she's super sweet but again you would
never know yeah like looking at her no
yeah Zach says turned the brightness
down you'd see better yet well that's
the thing we put a ring light back there
and so now it's like everything is okay
hold on so when you throw stuff in the
camera it's like it's a good idea to
turn the brightness down yeah
okay that's it's the ring light
that's a later
yeah yeah
that's that's not a usual look for her
but yeah right she was dressed up as
something yeah that's a manilator
yeah yeah
look at look at how Debonair you look I
know look at that [__] eyebrow yeah
that one eyebrow like cocked all up like
that so [__] smug yeah I was a
[__] prick you wearing prick yeah
you're still kind of a prick but not as
much of a prick as it used to be
you had a reputation for being a
president yeah yeah my reputation was
more of actually it exceeded the reality
it did you weren't you were never as big
a prick as people thought you were yeah
not saying you weren't a [__] I was
they just assumed I was more of a prick
than I did more of a perk than you
actually were
hilarious that was a hilarious time yeah
it was
this was like I said because I knew you
yeah but we weren't like going out at
the time dudes that were Gunner for were
like don't hang out with that dude he's
a [__] just and all kinds of [__] they
didn't no no which is dumb I wasn't
doing anything other people weren't
doing you weren't and actually I see
more [__] picky than those you were a
lot more restrained than most of the
people yeah like so I thought it was
ironic that people were just oh he's
such a [__] I'm like oh cause he went
out with one two one or two girls yeah
they were all good ones yeah I wasn't
slumming
I was a sluming I went with [__] good
ones it wasn't like
you know it's I don't know it was just
jealous it was yeah it was just weird
they talked about you like and then like
you were going around like [__]
banging like a different chick
everywhere it's like you weren't doing
that no and then the dude that did all
that though years later says man I'm
sorry about that he did Apologize he
apologized he was just trying to get in
your pants well yeah I mean you're just
trying to do what a dudes do
that dude used to text me all he was
[__] obsessed man like 30 or 40 times
a day yeah and that's when I was like
still married yeah I mean I was still I
mean I was in the process of divorcing
my husband we were still hanging out
like I didn't
I don't want anybody's like because when
I got divorced and when the [__] was it
2009 2010 something like that I think it
was 2009.
um it wasn't like a big huge traumatic
whatever I mean we stayed kind of friend
I don't talk to him anymore but we kind
of stayed friends at the time I think he
was mad
um but
it didn't um
it was fairly low drama as far as that
goes yeah
but you know desert Hope was a chlamydia
space chlamydia space chlamydia yeah he
was talking about like the poor the porn
movie where they had to rent two
spacesuits I'm like well okay so were
they regular space suits and it's like
if they had to [__] in them like how did
they get in and out of the spacesuits
were they crotchless space suits did
they make those no just vacuum and
[__] turn your [__] Inside Out ooh oh
it's almost nine o'clock
we don't have to go till 9 30. okay but
let me have one more let me have one
more drink uh I'm gonna give you mine
well that's only my first one though
because I have to uh I gotta drive
okay and I don't want to be like pissing
my brains out the whole drive there
High Desert 004 says uh I watched this
docu-series on Netflix about this girl
that disappeared in the Vatican they
think she was kidnapped for sex parties
with the pedo priests
that's that sounds uh
like probably what happened
um it's basically media
yeah and the Wilds parties probably
happened to the Vatican I kind of feel
like
man the more people like protest about
[__] and like talk about how
thank you
um
talk about how [__]
sinful everything is and how degenerate
people are and [__] like that I think
those people are doing like way worse
[__] than we ever did
I mean at least we're [__] open about
it
and no one no one involved in anything
that we're doing
we're not involving anybody that doesn't
want to be involved
um you know everyone's very kind of like
fine with it nobody is being forced into
anything nobody's being drugged nobody's
being you know what I mean
um so it's all just
fine
so I kind of feel like
I don't know and I always liked that
better
that it's just kind of like everything's
just kind of out in the open you know
what I mean
Zach's talking about the Bee Gees
I'm just honestly I'm I'm really glad
that you've discovered the BG's I'm not
they're not like my favorite or anything
but I actually really do like the bgs I
don't know if any if I would have said
that like back in the 80s or or back in
the 70s or 80s because I was like oh God
you know because I was all into like new
wave and post pockets of which I still
am but I'm just saying
um and I was like oh disco that's like
what my dad likes or whatever
um but the older I get I'm like you know
what the Bee Gees were actually like
really good and I did like that Sergeant
Pepper Movie if you haven't seen it Zach
you should probably watch that
it's bad but
I have like a real soft spot for it like
I grew up watching it a lot because it
used to be on like HBO and Cinemax and
stuff when I was growing up and the Bee
Gees are in it Peter Frampton is in it
it's super fun what you talking about
that Sergeant Pepper oh yeah yeah that's
like a and I'm not saying it's not a
good movie it's not it's terrible like a
music video it's terrible
it's also awesome yeah it's also don't
think about it too much you just watch
it it's just fun and you you get loaded
you get drunk or whatever you just it's
just like one big long music video that
kind of has a story arc to it
but it's kind of batshit crazy yeah but
but you're the one that's watching it
you're the one who bought into this [__]
you know what I mean just accept it I
love that movie and I'm not even like
I'm not saying it's a guilty pleasure
I'm not and I'm not making excuses I
love that movie it's it's a terrible
movie Sergeant Pepper's is just uh
it's just entertainment
sure good covers of Beatles songs
yeah buy it all and it's a ridiculous
story and I'm there I'm there for it I'm
there for it Aerosmith because I love
all of I love the piles of drugs that
they must have gone through to come up
with a storyline that linked all of
these bizarre ass Acid Trip songs
together yeah I love that I love that
somebody probably sat around
thinking how am I gonna link
all of these Beatles songs like
generally they were from Sergeant Pepper
some of them were from Abbey Road and
stuff as well so it's like how am I in a
link
Maxwell silver hammer with
um you know uh what's Golden Slumbers or
whatever like how am I gonna mix all
these together get back and it's like
yeah and it's like they made this whole
and it it makes sense I'm not saying it
doesn't make sense it does but
yeah it's a whole thing yeah that I
don't know I kind of there's like mind
control there I don't know if there's
all kind of crazy [__] going on it's
like it's all kind of crazy [__] think
of it as
a music video album
and it is a
Beatles tribute album Yeah by all by
disco and [__] rock ax it's got
[__] Aerosmith yeah it's got Alice
Cooper
it's got uh Steve Martin doing a [__]
uh yeah
um it's got BG's doing stuff what other
bands are jump in
um
let's see Aerosmith is in there
um Earth Wind and Fire Earth Wind and
Fire yeah they do get back yeah that's
actually like a really good they do a
good cover so I would call it a Beatles
tribute album movie
yeah it's good you know where they try
to make up their music's really good out
of a bunch of songs that don't have a
plot and that don't really go together
but they made a valiant effort and I
respect that you are supposed to be
tripping balls on LSD when you watch it
or Wii I think that's true
but it's still good it's just like
listening to an album it's like
listening to a tribute album that has a
music video going with it and it kind of
has a story
um
kind of reminds me of Phantom of The
Paradise but that's not a tributes that
that there's no covers in that it's just
in the style of other music
um
it's also kind of up there with Xander
do I like Xanadu a listener
I think requested xanaduate I think sent
it to me
yeah don't I have that I think I have I
think somebody sent me something
to review it and Tom loves musicals yeah
not all of them like not all of them I
love Greece I also love Greece and I
love Greece too it's okay I like the
television Greece that came out in the
2000 that was also pretty great very
good
um that was a live television event and
it's got more songs in it and more of
the story well it's more like the live
show so it's longer yeah
um
uh I liked fan of the paradise like repo
Genetic Opera uh we still haven't
reviewed that no we didn't we need to
[__] review that I like musicals
and I'm straight
the world's only straight man that likes
musical only straight man likes musicals
John Gore said is Travolta in Xanadu no
no he's not Olivia Newton-John carries
the movie though yeah Olivia Newton
John's in it she's great I didn't know
it because I I hadn't seen it since I
was a kid it's about uh some Greek
demigoddesses called the muses and they
were coming down and they were helping
guys
find their artistic way through life and
she plays a muse it's a good movie
and she had been coming here
for thousands of years helping guys and
in the story there's two guys that she
helped one of them when he was young I
was an old man and then this young guy
who's on there you know and it's just
it's just a good little movie
plus she roller skates a lot yeah and
that was very big it's not so much of
musical in the way other musicals are a
musical based on what I remember it just
kind of breaks out into song
it's a musical I still love that magic
song yeah every time that comes on
because sometimes I hear it in the
grocery store and imagine
the song that's a good song Olivia was
the [__] man
yeah she could sing and she was uh good
looking and very entertaining and and
she could she could act
at least you can act in a musical Tyler
the guy said I like Greece too more than
the first and I've gotten an endless
amount of [__] over that you're both
good I'm not gonna give you [__] about
it though because I honestly really like
grease too and like I said I'm not
guilty about that either I know I from
an objective standpoint it's not as good
as the first one but I still think it's
good Michelle Pfeiffer Michelle Pfeiffer
is cute as [__] in that movie like that
whole scene with her and Maxwell
Caulfield in the diner where they're
talking about Hamlet like in the burger
and everything it's like that I love
that [__] scene because it just kind
of seems so naturalistic like the way
they like interact with each other and
it's like that to me is like my favorite
scene in that [__] Movie the songs
aren't quite as good
um because they went like a little more
80s rock
um but I still think reproduction is a
hilarious song
um I still think that
um like some like the uh the big thing
they did at the end where they do like
the big talent show with the seasons and
everything like that's really good I
really like that song too like with
Michelle Pfeiffer in her little
Christmas tree outfit and all that kind
of [__] but yeah I really do like that
movie so don't feel bad because I like
that movie too and I'm not ashamed of it
either
Camp guy says I like to have at least a
modicum of human connection if I'm gonna
have sex with a girl
yeah I mean I'm the same I I don't think
that
maybe it's easier uh for dudes in
general to just like have sex with like
random people that they don't really
know
is that true yeah
but I'm not I'm I I can't really do that
I have to at least like like you
you know what I mean sex is not the same
it depends person to person there's some
kind sometimes you see a girl she's just
so hot
you want to have sex with her not
knowing her makes her hotter than it
would be if you knew her you know what
I'm talking about if you knew her you
might actually might not like her so
then the attraction would go away so I
understand both ways yeah because it's
like yeah she's hot but she might be
super interesting super dumb or she
might be like she just the [__] up
so it just depends
it depends but the thing is is that
different things are acceptable at
certain at different stages of your life
um the the not knowing the chick quick
encounter more of like a young guy thing
when I was young it was that was that
was pretty enticing
um when you get older you're more
suspicious so I'm not sure
it hasn't happened
so it
I'm not sure if the situation would be
the same I might be like nah [__] you
I know you're going to try to charge me
you're going to bill me for this aren't
you it's probably the [__] but when
you're 17 18 19 it's just like you know
she's not hooking but now I'd be
suspicious what do you want out of this
well yeah I mean the thing is too that
you have to think that if a very young
woman that doesn't know you yeah is
approaching an obviously older dude who
she doesn't know yeah then she has
probably has some ulterior motives well
it's also the same if it's an older
woman say yeah same exactly I would be
like no something I mean well generally
as a general rule whether you're old or
young or whatever if a woman approaches
you very aggressively sums up then yeah
that's not I mean normal and it's funny
because like sometimes young guys will
fall for that oh she digs me I'm like no
she's trying to get something she's
probably a hooker or she's trying to
like because like normally women will
not approach a dude like that normally
it depends on who you are when I depend
it depends
generally early 20s yeah because it was
a it was another young person then yeah
right they would
because the the game was different back
then and what they were looking for was
different they weren't worried about
money yet they were still living at home
everything was just you know living in
the moment it was you know what I mean
it was all just emotion and and you know
and everything was exciting so they were
more apt to like trying to do a quick
Rendezvous they didn't really quite
really didn't know you because it was
all new to them you know and yeah that
would happen
but no be honest as soon as a guy gets
in his 20s you're instantly a loser
because you have nothing to offer a
woman in her 20s not versus what a guy
in his 30s can offer
so being in your teens when you were a
guy me for me it was just [__] it was
easy it was great in high school
then you get out of the real world
and all of a sudden you got to compete
with guys in their 30s and you can't
you're gonna lose they got more money
they're they look better than you
everything they got cars houses whatever
well they're more stable they're more
stable so you're not going to end up
taking all their money or sleeping on a
couch or what so all the girls your age
20 20 21 they're all going with guys in
their 30s you just can't compete with
them
and that goes on a long time that's part
of the reason why I joined the army you
weren't I wasn't getting any action
so run it off to the Army for four years
bought me time
came out and kind of slayed it a little
bit half the time but really God isn't
coming to his own until he hits about
30.
I feel like that's true of a lot of
people yeah
I didn't I feel like I didn't really and
you know if you're younger than this
don't get discouraged because I didn't
really feel like I got my [__] together
until I was at least 35 yeah
at least and maybe closer to 40. to be
honest with you
by the time I started getting my late
30s early 40s I was like I got this
and I felt like that I got it you know
what I mean
I still feel like and [__] I'm 50 I'll
be 51 in September and I still feel like
man I don't even like feel like an adult
so
I didn't even really feel like an adult
until I was like in my mid to late 30s
so I get it like I get that people are
just kind of like what is this adulting
but it's because I had the same thing
and I'm you know and I'm older than
maybe some of you so it it happens to
everybody you don't really I don't know
I feel like I didn't get my [__] well
[__] I feel like I've just recently
gotten more [__] together yeah because I
have a lot of
um because we've been talking about this
a lot because of the uh you know all
those streamate and stuff like that
we've been doing and we've been talking
a lot about that and I just feel like it
has taken me this long in my life to
like get over
a bunch of like baggage and stuff that I
had like growing up you know you haven't
really talked to me about it yet so I
don't really I know I mean you know what
I'm saying you know what I'm talking
about right right right that's what I'm
talking about yeah because
um Camp guy was saying I grew up with
very religious parents and probably have
subconscious Hang-Ups about morality sex
and stuff yeah I kind of feel like like
I didn't grow up religious or anything
like that but
I I don't know I feel like I kind of had
a lot of weird Hang-Ups like that too so
just from and I don't really know where
they came from it didn't come from my
parents or anything but
I don't know maybe it's just my
personality or something but I just I do
feel like I didn't really get my [__]
together about that until
maybe like until I was like in my late
30s and maybe now
opening up a little bit more about that
you know it's just taken me a long time
so if you're younger than that it's like
don't feel bad like don't feel bad if
you haven't got your [__] together
because I don't have my [__] together
yeah and I'm like 50.
nobody gets their [__] together it's
just the way the world works I guess you
know what I'm saying yeah Tyler the guy
said I was a nobody in my teens and I'm
now a nobody at 21. it's rough out there
no 21 dude you hadn't even begun holy
[__] [__] up that's what I'm saying it's
like you haven't even begun man you
could be my kid at 21 which is [__] up
at 21. I was joining the Army
at 21.
because I went late compared to a lot of
guys so you don't even know what you're
talking about like I said I didn't even
get my [__] sorted out until I was like
38 years old and if you're a dude in
your 20s [__] [__] sucks you just
can't compete against the competition
you know the only girls that are really
interested in your [__] in their
teens so you can't be seen with them you
know you go to jail
[__] well not really I think I think
but in most States I think age of
consent is about 17 or 18 usually
but if and at your age you could get
away with it but those girls aren't
gonna [__] excite you too much
because they're just they don't have
anything you know I remember it when I
was 21 I wanted 21 22 20 25 you know
real well age appropriate well is that
age it's not really age appropriate
because you can only go because women
like a pergamy
they want to move up
so a 20 year old girl is really looking
at a 30 year old guy he's not looking
she's not looking at a 20 year old guy
I'm talking about anything I'm talking
about age-appropriate in the sense of
like dudes not going after like someone
way younger not way younger but a 20
year old 21 year old guy can go out with
an 18 year old girl no problem yeah
that's not weird yeah but yeah that's
what I mean they're not they're not
built up
to the level to where they can just kind
of stand with a [__] 21 22 23 year
old girl not in a club at least and I
was so Club oriented you know although
some could but you couldn't take them
drinking
see that's another thing if you're real
into and especially like if you're into
the god scene and everything like that
it kind of behooves you to like go meet
somebody that's at least 21. right
because there's a lot of I mean there's
some that don't drink okay I'm not
saying you have to drink but it is a
culture that's very based around clubs
and some clubs you can't go to unless
you're 21. so you have an 18 year old
boyfriend or girlfriend you're gonna
you're gonna have a hard time right
you're gonna have a hard time because
it's like maybe you can take them some
places but they can't drink and
so it's going to be a whole thing Tammy
said I have a 30 year old daughter yeah
I mean
I mean I could have a 30 year old
daughter yeah I hear some of this I can
I listen to some of these videos
I guess they've been coined like the
manosphere guys complaining about women
or talking about women who are
complaining about men you know on
[__] they'll take they'll live
they're the worst they'll lift these
videos off of tick tock where some girls
complaining about guys and they'll pick
it apart see what she's talking about
it was funny about these dudes man and
these are mostly dudes in their 20s I
think maybe 30s
they keep saying that a woman's value
kind of disappears after 30. then once
she hits 30 you know what I mean she's
not really the [__] anymore you know
what I mean and I'm like and this is
like loser 21 year old saying this yeah
and people care about their opinion why
well I don't think this loser 21 year
olds I think they're as old as in their
30s
[Laughter]
listen to these dudes and I'm like these
[__] don't know anything about
women uh obviously okay because really
they start getting good after 30.
women in their 20s are dig bats man they
make some stupid decisions I mean guys
make students everybody makes stupid
decisions that's kind of like what your
teens and 20s are all about making
stupid decisions right and hopefully
learning from them and and [__]
some of the the hottest ones but they
they kind of have this weird [__]
thing that after 30 they're not
physically attractive I don't know what
the [__] she's talking about
we know women that are approaching 40
that are just [__] drop dead gorgeous
I mean [__] uh
[__] Laura Laura Ross she's pushing 40.
you wouldn't know it by looking at her
and I've known her since she was [__]
mid mid 20s maybe 24 25. what are the so
whether these [__] dudes talking
about they don't get out much they don't
get out much I think what the problem is
and then um or their low-key pedophiles
Jen draven's 50 something right well
she's she's a couple years younger then
so she's late she's in her mid to late
40s yeah and she's and she's got two
kids that are grown yeah like she's got
two daughters that are grown and she
knocks most women in their 20s uh she's
she's beautiful long black hair
and uh she's just you know
so I don't know who these dudes are
seeing I mean where do they live I mean
yeah who are they hanging out for I'd go
down to the Oasis you know little biker
bar and find a lot of 50 something year
old women they look like [__] hags
because they they but they look like
hags at 25. they look like hags at 30.
the way they were drinking
math is a hell of a [__] truck okay
interesting so this is Florida they're
[__] yeah they've been been rolled
four or five times in [__] Chopper
accidents and [__] like that one
shoulder higher than the other
they're biker women you know I mean yeah
they're 50 they're [__] up not all of
them though they had that one who was
like 73 who came in with a her [__]
28 year old artist
tattoo artist boyfriend and she was
smoking hot
she was 72. but she was a model okay she
had made her living as a model
uh so it you can't tell you I mean you
never you got you can't you don't you
can't stereotype until you see him see
the woman it's just very narrow-minded
it's very narrow-minded it's not just
about age there's a lot of fat look at
look at [__] um uh [__] girl
played Elvira oh [__] Cassandra
Cassandra Peterson she's 75 I think
74. she's smoking hot
same thing with [__] Luanna Quigley
the uh
Quigley she's what 60 something
she's I think she's in her 60s 60s yeah
still [__] great looking they're just
they got some women out there that whole
that can hold their own for a long time
Jen's 50 and [__] she beat a lot of
women in their 30s
yeah easily yeah she beats the average
woman in her [__] 30s easily yeah
because I'm thinking what average it
looks like so yeah no problem so age
isn't the [__] deciding factor on a
woman's attractiveness
there's a lot more too yeah I've never
really
um got too hung up on that no there's a
lot of different factors they got
cougars out there
which that's one of the angles Jen can
is going to be using on [__] stream
mating some of this well that's gonna be
wrong one of the tags yeah
we got [__] fans here
from this YouTube channel here that
[__] we talked to offline [__]
like Oscar Oscar [__] loves Jen
[__] that's his favorite [__] golf
cougar okay and how old is Oscar
probably uh yeah I think he was the late
20s or earlier yeah so just you know I
understand it yeah I like older women
too if they're hot
you know they're out there
that's the thing I'm not real concerned
about people's ages no I'm just kind of
concerned like what they look like and
what what are they like yeah you know
what I mean it doesn't really matter how
well they are well like I said I've said
this before too because I think remember
like somebody because I always kind of
like make jokes about oh [__] old
people or whatever but it's like I'm old
too so I'm not
I'm not talking about old like as age
I'm talking about old as in like
attitude you know what I mean because
I've known some like people in their 20s
that seem like old people to me yeah
Tyler's talking about he thinks that
most guys in the manosphere grifting
yeah I agree yeah they are they're just
trying to make videos yeah and they're
they're looking for content and they
know that like there's a subset of dudes
out there that will click on all that
because they're like yeah man I'm not
getting laid yeah [__] that [__] and
it's all the bitch's fault yeah it's not
like they have to improve themselves
because that's why you need to go to the
gym or learn how to [__] dress or
[__] become an attractive guy or
heaven forbid well see yeah well that's
what I mean I kind of feel like yeah
it's easier to just blame the women for
not paying attention to you Elliot Roger
yeah then just like being a cool person
yeah well Roger looked okay he was just
[__] artistic or something there was
something well no he was a psychopath
was his problem yeah but he couldn't
interact for some reason there was more
to it than that it was a bunch problems
on that guy and I think everybody within
a five mile radius like as soon as they
met him were like ooh red flags all
around because he just came off like
very very [__] right weird so my if
if any of you guys in there listening to
the manosphere here's my advice
don't I've done well with women my whole
life
number one thing don't focus on women I
never really focused on them I never
really chased them what I was doing is I
was always worried about my [__]
developing
my character
and developing my wardrobe and
developing my skills not to get women it
was just what I like to do
The Joint I think that's what a lot of
dudes don't they they're too goal
oriented it's like you know what I mean
and without a transaction women can
smell that yeah miles away right it's
not a transaction because this is not a
machine where oh if I do this then I
will get this from women yeah we're not
vending machines yeah that will they
they can sense that [__] of certain mile
away it's creepy yeah that's not what it
is what it is is become a person become
a good person and have fun and don't
[__] stress out on that [__] yeah
don't worry develop yourself and and and
and and and and do your own thing all
right and be interesting yeah right
you'd be a rock climber be a [__]
skateboarder be a [__] motorcycle
racer anything a musician an artist
anything filmmaker it's more about
Brandon be interesting women don't want
to be with the average [__] they
want to be with a dude that has some
kind of a brand or an identity to it so
oh he's one of these
and uh but the thing is is that you
can't do it artificially like well what
should we have interests yeah don't have
it that's the thing John gloriously he
put it really well he said being too
interested in women is a turn off for
women ironic it is yeah because like I
said it comes across as creepy and
desperate yeah and creepy and desperate
are two things you do not you're a lot
more attractive to women if you're hot
and ignoring them they [__] love that
like not ignoring necessarily but just
like not aloof yeah just like being like
hey I got my own [__] going on but like
I said yeah they don't need you yeah
you're not a needy guy right the thing
that I liked about you I mean when I
first met you one you were a really good
dresser you uh you know dance really
good also I liked that you had a lot of
friends and they were males and females
and you weren't like banging all the
females they were just like your genuine
friends like you had friends that were
women yeah that were that you had never
slept with or anything like that they
were just like you just liked them yeah
friends with ugly women like as people
yeah it didn't matter if they were ugly
or anything if I liked them I'd [__]
you know I'd be kissing on some girl
she's ugly but
it's not just because I try to [__] or
anything I like her
right you know what I mean hey baby
because we all kiss on each other anyway
at the club we're all drunk right but
see that's what I liked about it is that
you actually had for and you were
friends with all your exes which is
always a good yeah sign like they still
like you yeah which is always good
well usually we broke up for things that
didn't really wasn't didn't have
anything to do with us it was more of a
situational that's what I'm saying like
like when me and with me and Elita we
were both in a bad time coming out of
other relationships at the time so we're
kind of hanging out with each other to
[__] kinda to kind of make each other
feel better because we you know we could
go to the club together right but we
didn't really have that [__] romantic
spark between us right which I think is
part of the reason why Jan [__] liked
her too because I don't think Chad
realized that we're gonna run off with
her and she wasn't gonna run off with me
we me and Elena didn't really have that
kind of relationship it was in a weird
way it doesn't sound in a weird in a
weird way it was kind of like dating a
cousin or a sister or some [__] like
that
I like Elena because Elena is awesome
yeah she is super sweet and she is super
nice and I just really I didn't have
that [__] romantic drive for though
and we just kind of called it quit
but then a week later we're hanging out
the club together it did yeah it didn't
matter like I said it's
you see it sometimes
um because the god scene in Florida is I
mean it's large-ish but it's small
enough that everybody knows everybody or
at least knows somebody that knows that
person like you know it's one removed
and a lot of people have dated other
people or you know this person that
dated this other person
and I will say that
um for everybody in the scene that's
dated one another because a lot of
people have
um there's relatively little drama there
is some sometimes and I know that like
you know people outside of the godson
are always like oh drama and everything
like that I don't think we have as much
drama as like normal yeah scenes have no
there is drama I'm not saying there's
there's not uh because there there isn't
the same insecurities but yeah that
would normally happen and honestly a lot
of people that break up
um will usually remain friends yeah
um because they have a lot of friends in
common yeah so it's like you can't
really and there's not that many clubs
to go to so you have to go to the same
place so you have to kind of like learn
to like adapt Camp guys asking about
Andrew Tate yeah I've listened to Andrew
Tate I believe um
um I agree with most of what he says
I in general like him but you have to
understand that Andrew Tate is coming
from the position of a very young guy
he's young and brash he doesn't he he he
can't see things exactly the way I got
his 50s sees things
but for his age he he's
what he's saying
works for a younger guy it doesn't work
for an older guy I'm not saying he's
wrong it's just as you go through
different stages in life your reality
changes a lot and the way you deal with
reality is different
um You Gotta Love The Audacity Of like
some 20 odd year old dude like giving
advice on anything but yeah it's like
very funny he can though he's got
millions of dollars well sure but it's
like that doesn't necessarily mean that
he's any smarter or like knows anything
well then better than anyone else well
they were they were asking about women
and he's got a lot of women working for
him who are like the uh they're like
streaming girls
and uh he talks a lot about
relationships he's a manisphere guy
that's what he's talking about yeah yeah
he's
he's mostly correct especially from his
age group and where he lives and the
type of women he's dealing with
um
in general
his advice is pretty sound
if you're a young guy listening to him
the advice
if if he were giving me the advice a lot
of times I don't need that advice
because I've already been through that
okay
or I could say yeah that's good general
advice but at my age I could get around
that problem you're just looking at it a
different way you're not looking at it
the right way that kind of [__] you know
what I mean but it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter
like I said I think John Gore has put it
really well because I think the problem
is that younger guys the reason that
they come across the way they come
across in a lot of uh at a lot of times
is because
they are again very goal oriented
they're just trying to well I'm just
trying to get laid well it's like well
women are like well that like I said I'm
not a vending machine I don't really
want you to like do all of these tricks
on me yeah it's like and they're very
transparent like it's really obvious to
a woman like I don't know if dudes know
how obvious they are when they're doing
that okay okay the guys he's talking
about are not doing that though the guys
that he that he is talking about like
Tay mostly what they're talking about is
how to separate good reliable women that
are marriage material away from say like
just your average hoe that's basically
what he's talking about the thing is is
a lot of those guys
a lot of those a lot of those guys have
a [__] lack of trust for women
which there's something to be said for
that there are a lot of bad women out
there
well yeah there's a lot of bad a lot of
bad men out there but you can't
stereotype a woman just based on certain
things like body care how many men have
they been like I said we're not the
board it's like everybody's different
sometimes a woman has been with a lot a
lot of guys but maybe because they're
she was monkey branching from one to the
next and they were all kind of losers
and she was trying to get out of the
situations as much as she could but she
needed security that doesn't necessarily
mean she's gonna [__] you over you have
to have a good relationship with that
particular woman a good understanding
with her some woman some dudes can't do
that some dudes don't have the
personality to actually get to know some
chick they're not
built for it yet they're too young
they're too inexperienced
there's a lot of problems and then
another thing is that some dudes get too
[__] love struck too quickly
yeah I've run it so they're all of a
sudden trying to get all [__]
committee and commitment with some chick
that really doesn't like you yet all
right and that's that's a recipe which
is very funny to me because I kind of
feel like in the larger scheme of things
I kind of feel like dudes in general
have a thing it's like oh women they
just want to like [__] get committed
too quickly and stuff like that in my
experience it's the opposite yeah it's
the opposite this goes back to something
I said about or in the other show about
um what was it what what they call it
Stockholm syndrome okay when we were
talking about Patty Hearst yeah Patty
Hearst with Stockholm chair
evolutionary biology and evolutionary
psychology and [__] is involved in this
men even non-human men in other words
male animals
are because of testosterone in their
biochemistry and [__] are driven to
reproduce it's like hunger
what was selected for survival is a guy
who could attach quickly and mate
quickly all right and he would be there
to help raise the children in higher
primates okay and and also in mammals
okay not all mammals but most of the
mammals
ah
what was selected in women
was to actually
Bond slowly because they had to choose
which one well we have a lot more
[__] and we have a lot more news
obviously and they also were selected to
detach quickly because if the male got
killed they had to quickly switch to
another male they couldn't get hung up
in that got to move on gotta move on so
you see that in part of the [__] uh
Stockholm syndrome is that oh well I was
with this guy we had a kid new males
came and they killed him because he
wasn't strong enough to defend himself
and me they killed the kid he's gone
these other guys are pretty strong
though and I need protection from other
dudes like this and this one here he's
okay he didn't kill my husband I can
meet with him and not have any problem
and it won't happen again so that's
basically what Stockholm syndrome is and
that's how animals work that's how Lions
do [__] it's uh primates can sometimes
do that so that's
that's what this detaching quickly and
then uh you know select you know
selecting a mate kind of slowly that's
that's a woman thing and it's kind of
what happened in nature
even with non-human ancestors we're
we're related to things that aren't
human of course you know I [__] you
can go back to Australopithecus
the australopithecines and
Homo erectus and [__]
Neanderthal if you're white you have
some Neanderthal and you have very few I
think some even some black people have
some Neanderthal in them it depends on
what party of the world you're from but
yeah I think white people have more
right like a higher percentage it's not
it's still not a tiny percentage but
yeah but they you know we bread in with
each other yeah if they enter in with
each other they're like human close
enough right so we've inherited some of
these things some of these survival
skills from non-human ancestors
so these dudes are all worried about
this [__] like no dude you were selected
to breed quickly
because you probably not going to live
long because in the wild you don't all
right you'd be lucky to raise one child
before you get killed and then you're
gonna be replaced by another guy who is
better than you
and that's what's happened that's the
day deal with it that's the dating world
right there isn't it that's the dating
world right there well I mean like in a
very simplistic way sure but like I said
I do
it's funny because I do kind of feel
like there is still kind of it's you
know lessened in recent years but I do
kind of feel like there is still kind of
a perception that women get more
emotionally attached and stuff like that
in my experience it has not been that
way I feel like men get more attached
they don't admit it yeah but like um I
found that like after breakups and stuff
like that where I'm just like buy it you
know what I mean and it's like I don't
really care but it's like dude yeah they
just keep calling you and they keep you
like it's that kind of [__] they're
trying because they got them please stop
calling me yeah you know what I mean
just want another one I don't give a
[__] about you just like please go away
but it's like they left to their own
they won't detach right and go look
right I mean that's like I said that's
just been my experience it's true that
it's like I'm very much like when I'm
done I'm done I'm just like I don't want
to hear from you anymore I don't want to
see you anymore I don't want to think
about you anymore I'm out of here but
they just keep wanting to re-engage yeah
yeah that's a very male Behavior right
especially if they didn't go through
that at an early age and resolve that
and understand that that's how the
system works
you go oh okay yeah can't do it can't
get her back I gotta go find another one
but that's kind of against human
instinct especially when you're a
teenager
but you have to do that when you're a
teenager dudes that don't go through
that when they're a teenagers and do
that [__] in their 20s and 30s
and it looks bad it does it looks real
bad I wish that more Deeds would
experience
rejection in their teenage years so they
learned to deal with it well they don't
in a healthy way because you're going to
everyone experiences it men women
everyone you're not going to experience
rejection if you never if you never make
a move on a girl and a lot of these guys
now never and even back in the day would
not make a move on them in high school
so they were just single to those
through all the high school so they
never got any experience and if you
didn't get experience with rejection
then when you got older then it would
get worse and worse because then
somebody rejected you and then you'd
[__] blow up because you'd never like
[__] dealt with it it would be a big
thing if you went through the through
success and failure rejection and
acceptance in your teen years all of a
sudden you you're mentally moved into
the realm of plenty
abundance there's a lot of women there
isn't just one there's a lot of them so
you don't have that oh I gotta get her
back you don't have that in you anymore
you're like she don't want me I'll get
another one
more fish in the sea
that looks a lot better it makes you a
lot more attractive it does because
women see that and they go okay yeah he
doesn't need these women
he's got his own [__] going on because I
think women it's weird because I think I
feel like men have like and I'm just
using like saying in a general sense
because I know like not everybody's the
same but I kind of feel like men haven't
they need to be needed
yeah yeah women not so much no I kind of
feel like if women are needed too much
it gets weird and like they feel start
feeling like suffocated men need to be
needed it's part of their [__] uh
programming that goes back to birds
[__] male birds showing up with
sticks trying to make the nest you need
me to help build this Nest right that's
what here I brought some pretty bottles
here look look hang them up on the wall
[__] silver tinsel look at that [__]
yeah that's what they're doing
Bower Birds yeah look that [__] up it's
hilarious and women take that a weird
way of their life they do they take they
don't really I take it a weird way it's
weird yeah it's not from the male point
of view the the guys want to be useful
or yeah they get that they want to but
they want to help I mean if a woman
doesn't need your help it's not you
don't like her it's just that oh she
doesn't need me I'm gonna find you know
I'm gonna go away that's all it is but
women I think and like I said I'm not
speaking for all women for me personally
and like other women I've known and that
comes across as like very overbearing
because you're you're suggesting well
you're suggesting that it's like oh
you're suggesting that I can't do [__]
for myself like I'm helpless that's how
you're taking it that's not well no
that's how that's how women would take
it yeah I think just you so it comes
across women like you do that but that's
not what he means what he means is he's
trying to be useful
because men are mostly about utility
yeah you know what I mean so he's like
well if I'm not useful to her then she
doesn't need me so I'll go where I need
it and so I'm gonna piss off yeah I'm
gonna piss off she can she can take care
of herself she doesn't need me and that
just means you can have a bunch of
single a bunch of single lonely women
around if dudes are like ah [__] them
you know they don't need us they don't
want us because need and want is about
the same thing to these men
right okay
but need to a woman is feels that that
idea is kind of insulting to them
because I guess they're they're pissed
off at being stereotyped as being weak
yeah and needy men don't have that yeah
so need and want is the same thing in
the mind that's who I said it's not but
to a woman It Isn't So it's it's like a
miscommunication it's two different
things it's mostly a miscommunication a
guy doesn't see himself as being
valuable in terms of beauty he only sees
himself invaluable in terms of his
skills and what he can do yeah I get
that in terms of utility right of his
utilities so he wants to be utilized
that's a good way to put it right he
wants somebody to put him to work and do
a job so because for him for a male
this is kind of like a bird building a
nest I'll help you the house I'll help
you make the house I'll help you I'll
fix your car right I'll [__] do this
I'll help you do this if that's what
he's trying to do right I'm a good man
I'll be there for you that's what he's
that's what he's thinking and I get that
it's just it's hard for me because I'm
kind of like and I'm like I said again
not speaking for all women but it's like
I do kind of feel like that comes across
as a little bit like I think you can't
do things for yourself because I'm like
I can do most things for myself so I
don't really yeah but some of this
shit's real Primal like my main things
is this guy says I will protect you from
men who are trying to attack you or rape
you I will help I will help protect you
right that's what that's the one of the
biggest things yeah okay that's one of
the things where you know you have like
especially in real rough areas or in bad
parts of the world uh smaller guys are
at the bottom of the pack because they
can't but in in the hood too because
they can't provide any protection
physical protection of these women
who's being selected there big old
bruisers
somebody who's terrifying enough to
scare other dudes away
and that's the way it was in [__] you
know
in in in you know in primitive times and
actually that's not that far that's not
that long ago you know you're gonna go
back a couple hundred years here in the
United States and those are the guys
that would be selected
guys that were [__] terrifying
oh he's a good man they're scared yeah
you know yeah I get that yeah like I
like intellectually I get it but like I
said it's two you're coming at it from
two different
mindsets and both of the mindsets are
legitimate yeah because you have to
understand is that these dudes are not
thinking this is emo this is emotion
right it's they're not thinking it
they're not analyzed they're not this is
this is emotion and instinct
and and it's kind of like the default
setting and the the shame the bad thing
about it is that modern education does
not teach men what they are it is not
teaching them what they are and what
they were built to do and to um and to
tell them about these internal programs
that they're built with that they're
that well that might be useful to tell
them you're doing this because well this
is what your ancestry did I mean tell
them that and like also tell them look
like women are coming at it from like
this point of view which is still
legitimate because like I said we're not
right aliens they can't do that nowadays
because half the damn country thinks
that there's no difference between men
and women oh there's differences
because humans are animals and you just
look at the animal kingdom and a lot of
it's just biology biology and hormones
I inject a one if I were to inject a
woman with a [__] ton of testosterone
not only will you become masculine
you'll become a man
and you'll be thinking and acted just
like dude like me
all right they're out there heaven
forbid yeah
I mean you did like a lot of it is you
gotta like injected me with a lot of
hormones but you did like mess my voice
up that went back to normal
it's still like lower than it was though
it's androgens yeah yeah Zach says by
the way didn't you guys need to go
somewhere at 9 30. yeah yeah we gotta go
we gotta go well it's 9 35 we're all
right yeah like I said we don't have to
be there right when they open they're
right they open right at 10 but I mean
and I'm pretty much ready I just have to
put I just have to pee and put shoes on
yeah but yeah all right so um all right
so sorry it's a little abrupt but yeah
we we gotta go we're gonna go out to uh
momentum worry this evening and they
open at 10 so we gotta get on the road
so hopefully you guys uh enjoyed this
rambling discussion this evening uh
we'll be back on Sunday and we're going
to be talking about casino because uh
xanadas sent us that so we're gonna
watch it tomorrow night and uh you know
and I've been wanting to do that movie
because I really like that movie so
we're going to be talking about that on
Sunday so hopefully you guys can join us
for that
so have a good day tomorrow have a good
rest of your evening tonight and we will
see you guys again on Sunday
good night